he don't need no shrooms to do that when
the shrooms dig in
oh boo lay cat podcast special guest in
here
g perico yeah yeah yeah dupree jainari
yes sorry okay well parikho you were
just on the show yeah so you got to tell
me what is going on so i just i i wanted
to bring the clique with me you know
okay
dupreeh
jay nori you know what i'm saying you
heard him whoa whoa
legendary first of all you guys are some
legends in the city man uh on some on
some producer [ __ ] like i feel like you
guys uh
don't get enough credit the league of
stars
in general just as a a unit
was very much synonymous with
the west coast sound that was popping
nationally in fact
so
salute to y'all thank you bro appreciate
it people who don't know who you guys
are what you guys have made you guys
have made some amazing songs that we all
know just kind of give us a run down you
know
uh yeah so so mine goes starting from
like tied me down i did uh
tie me down shout out to ray j she ain't
gonna tie me down the new boys what
happened to the new boys man that was a
great record man they ain't gonna tie me
down so unfortunately but yeah like they
had a cool run one of them was [ __ ]
tenache before anyone knew who tinashe
was yeah i like tanasha
shout out i think it was like
power 106 92 one of them big concerts at
one of them amphitheaters
and power 106. yeah i'm like i told earl
when i was with roc nation i'm like take
me to uh meet tanasha right quick you
know what i'm saying take me back
come on
you know what i mean yeah nice all right
tie me down
yeah so i did tie me down um i did like
well for problem i did it
what yeah yeah i did uh i don't want her
for eric ballinger
yeah okay okay stop for game uh oh i
remember the thought record good box
yeah
yeah then you know just a bunch of a
bunch of other random [ __ ] like i did
high right now for tyler yahweh
ah that's a part of that shout out to
tyler yahweh shout out
wait there was a remix to that too right
yeah
with whiz yeah
tyler looks like wiz's doppelganger or
his illegitimate child
i was the perfect person to get on that
but
yeah you know and then recently i just
been doing you know i did the play to
win executive produced it nice reggie
you know there it is play to win i was
on the five freeway in the finish pass a
ganger she did a gang of [ __ ] all right
what about you man goddammit dupree bro
uh [ __ ]
produce the walkthrough for richard
mccartney problem bobby fan that's a big
record
um produced uh down for g-eazy shout out
to mulatto and uh [ __ ] then gelato lotto
yeah i'm my best friend a lot of big a
lot of my bad lotto but uh and then uh i
produced la summers vegeta like the full
project and then we got tango but that's
about to drop next friday she got more
[ __ ] than that
i mean that's just come on man you know
what yeah
ricky
oh
yeah and then um some [ __ ] that i got
coming uh next week i got we got tango
then i got a record with ruby rose
dropping next friday have you hung out
with ruby rhodes i haven't yet she
finding someone [ __ ] it up it's cool
though i mean i'm just good on the
production whether it's all good you
know yeah i'm just wondering like i've
been contemplating like
i've never signed up for an only fans
account
but i know she hasn't
so i was just wondering if you guys had
seen it because i'm like oh not even
though i wasn't where she had i made
this fine you know well they do got
reddit right where you could just get
all that [ __ ]
yeah everything is free already
what'd you say she should feature me on
our only fans featuring parikho
you know i did do the bio pic with the
porno store you know
well yeah i got that record coming
that's co-produced with my boy uh
extendo and uh mike crook
shout out hey well i just saw two you
posted uh your first plaque was with
tyga
first platinum plaque yeah i produced
four records on the legendary on his
last army drop
and that was the album was that the um
that's the one where he had a taste on
it oh yeah i mean yeah that's the one
yeah thank god i was a part of that so
yeah i should went that was like come
back
platinum that was the comeback album
right there yeah so we thought tiger was
dead they said nope peers didn't didn't
yeah we actually got some emotion to
come actually for his next [ __ ] so
tiger's a beast yeah you know you always
come with that one or two that's how you
know don't give it you you can't give
this [ __ ] up you can't you can't give up
i always tell you everybody's always a
hit away we were just talking about rich
homie quan right yeah rachel mcqualin
was like that [ __ ] he got into a
shitty label situation
his label wasn't letting him release
music and then like
i don't know it just just [ __ ] was
it just ain't what it was but but he had
it though right and he could get it back
he's still he's one record away
like think about it t-pain last year had
a top 20 or top 10 song at radio he
really did the song with kailani you
know that was his record yeah he sampled
himself
that's fine i need to simple walk
through there so it's like you're just
one record away everyone's always one
record away definitely that's a dog ja
rules one record away i know i don't
know about job
he came all the way back
you ain't lying
he didn't come all the way back but he
came back
for y'all to play him but i mean yeah
you can't you can't really count people
out because you never know 100 bounce
back i really i think it's a
like consistency like if you keep
dropping and dropping they keep hearing
you eventually all right that's what hey
honestly loki that's what tiger was
doing he just kept dropping [ __ ] and
then something especially caught on like
you know because a lot of that [ __ ]
wasn't it yeah i'm saying but it's hard
to beat a [ __ ] that don't quit
man ain't that the truth ain't that the
truth the one that don't quit always
reap those rewards though who probably
isn't one record away
is there anybody
um that's just not gonna be able to come
back even with the most fire record i
feel like it could be anybody anybody
honestly yeah especially with like
tick-tock and like like even if it's
funny you know like you know like [ __ ]
anymore unless they got a good beat and
a hard hook anybody can come back i'm
sorry
like i don't know if vanilla ice got got
one
all right yeah when you take it i
i don't think he could get that though
vanilla
y'all
i listened to that [ __ ] the other night
that ice hey that whole back story on
that crazy didn't you buy
somehow he got hung off of a balcony in
l.a yeah i thought and that's what
bernie sanders
some nice golden urine
oh [ __ ] wait pee in the cup and make
[ __ ] drink it don't like me i ain't
never heard
we just heard
this guy was out here drinking that
goddamn that anhyzer [ __ ] that
anheuser-busch for real
jesus that's terrible well uh okay so
your new project
you guys are just talking uh off the
record so you're start
these guys are handling all the
production for the most part yeah like
[ __ ] 90 percent everything why not
make it 100
100 yeah because i mean that would make
sense
everything that i do you know what i'm
saying
meg shoris
we planned it we playing the pause game
about pause
yeah but yeah
january hit all the records and [ __ ]
yeah so you're like you're like you're
the architect you are the everything's
gotta he's the over everything's gotta
go through your hands before it gets the
the approval yeah yeah so jake already
touched everything me and do pre-do
project he got songs on everything that
i did for like the last few years but um
yeah i forgot the [ __ ] question now
we did the pause game
but yeah now we we pretty much doing
doing the production on on everything
from
you know the end of i say the 21 flood
to hurricane yeah i mean we talked about
this a bit
obviously you're
you love
me and you were talking about this in
the gym we talked about on the podcast a
few months ago just your new situation
you could just do whatever the [ __ ] you
want whenever the [ __ ] you want
yeah
right and this and that's gonna make
sense for me and you know in the long
run and like up front like i'm saying
like
we feel good about something we drop it
ain't got to go explaining and
getting a zillion people behind it and
differences of opinions and all that
[ __ ] make you just hate doing music
now we just i do pre we got to do
preview on me you know what i'm saying
like what is we doing
this [ __ ] send me so much music every
day like we got like a [ __ ] loaded up a
shitload of records you know what i mean
and uh
i feel like what we're doing right now
is just like cultivating a new scene
in los angeles or i mean it's the same
scene but just a new ethic and a new
outlook and a new a new way to approach
it because
like on some real [ __ ] they've been
getting boring as [ __ ] out here
[ __ ] drop one thing and then
play the high celebrity [ __ ] ain't
nobody getting dirty we don't see [ __ ]
in the streets
driving under that [ __ ] pulling up out
dropping records doing like nothing yeah
i mean it's just you know all internet
[ __ ] so
you know we're getting busy with the
flood you know what i mean just to click
and um you know we just opening doors
for the i feel like the independent
the independent era the independent
market for this streaming era
is untouched untapped and i know you
love the streaming yeah yeah a lot of
streams so it's untapped and untouched
in la and it's kind of like still
foreign to a lot of people you know what
i mean so what we doing is bringing that
to the forefront and letting
[ __ ] know like if you got
something good
you need to od
go in yeah
uh i gotta ask you because problems like
what was like a moment
a big moment for for the city man like
that was like um
that was [ __ ] crazy i just remember
that record and like how it
cut through just i was living in
no i was living in phoenix at the time
but that song was such a s
that song changed a lot of people's
lives yeah yes
um how did it like like tell me about
that song it just that
you know i love that that run problem
was on the the mollywood runs like i
mean you know
i feel like
he had it for like you know cool three
years i feel like like when i thought of
la i thought a problem you know what i'm
saying like and he's still doing this
thing obviously but that specific record
changed a lot
yeah so with that record like
um that was the last record that we did
on you know that that uh project and
problem produces himself
um and you know he he had the ideal for
it and everything and
you know he just brought it to me
um and i just kind of put my my mix on
it um and you know my drums and and just
turned it around like you know changed
the main lead and you know it just went
crazy
yeah that [ __ ]
yes for a while you guys had you guys
had the same manager so he just kind of
had the pick of the litter of the league
of stars beats for a while there yeah
but that was like at that that was early
right yeah at that point so we was
coming out of the jerk era
and you know like i had a bunch of
records in the jerk area i was like
popping you know and then
it died out which which records did you
have so like from the jerk area of
course tie me down um i did shia model
for yg
um and just a bunch of like just random
stuff like taft like everybody that was
pretty much popping and um
like it started to die out my name
started to you know kind of fizzle out
with it as well and i started seeing
like the pre-denies which who are my
homies you know from
way back uh they were starting to come
up so you know like i joined league of
stars and like
that was like really my turn around
record because i was just trying to
put something out you know i didn't have
no records out there who didn't function
that was training
yeah so at that time that just
that just kind of turned everything
around for me and you know like just re
you know introducing myself back into
the scene you know
from going from that fad to you know
like hey i just saw um did the new boys
just release a new jerking song nah it
just went uh well i don't know if they
released it
i know that it went re-viral but i heard
someone yesterday told me it's random
because i was just talking about the new
boys yesterday you're a jerk i know
someone was like yeah they just put a
new version out oh i mean yeah they
wouldn't be surprised yeah i wouldn't be
surprised i mean it's going up so it'll
be small take advantage yeah take
advantage of that [ __ ] tie me down wow
yeah that was a joint man that was my
yeah yeah
what was your name's legacy and ben jay
i was doing so much illegal [ __ ] around
that time man end up getting tied down
by the state of california
literally literally
moscow
la county
it's over now
so when you guys are working on g [ __ ]
like what is the
you know do you guys collaborate on
stuff like
for sure yeah like we we've been
collaborating for like
almost 10 years now right so you know
with g stuff like we both bring a
certain sound to g and then you know now
we're just putting it together
and kind of like
adding our flavors together so like if
you you heard the song the interview and
you produced the first half of the song
i produced the second half oh dope
see i like the cohesive when like that's
why i love what hit boy's doing with
like benny the butcher with knives just
like he was just talking about that he's
just talking about it's very cohesive
you know jam sport jays in there too
doing his thing but like just it just i
feel like right now in hip-hop like you
know freddy gives us that whole alfredo
got nominated for a grammy fully
produced by uh alchemists but just that
cohesive like
sound
for a project to me is so like
i think it's like clutch yeah for a
producer i think that's important too
though like
because uh like we get so trapped in a
to chasing placements and you know just
trying to work with like the artist
that's hot when you and you will get a
hot record and the artist won't even
work with you after that so it's like
it's kind of cool to have you know like
ownership you know and just build you
know and i think a lot of producers are
are kind of like looking past that it's
another way to make money build your
catalog and really build your legacy too
yeah talk to me about tags because you i
don't even what's your tag
goddammit dupree okay god damn it dupree
i know he's sorry jane
but like the tag [ __ ] is so important
and like i feel like there was a lot of
producers hit boys one of them i had a
conversation with him or he was like man
for the forever i would never use a tag
and
meanwhile you know some of my peers
would be [ __ ]
so brandable because their tag was so
you know and so now hit boys got a
[ __ ] tag on there he's got like three
different ones he uses but like it's so
important how important is like the tag
for a producer because i do feel like
there are there were there's a lot of
producers who don't use tags still but
like for like branding and just for like
recognition like if someone says like
you're janari and if they've heard a
certain they're like oh yeah [ __ ] i know
your [ __ ] you know what i mean like how
important is the tag especially in the
in the beginning is
like detrimental because that's i mean
that's
that's you that's your stamp that's your
name you know like that's how people can
you know like
i never seen you i never heard you but
you know i heard that tag you know so
it's important to have a tag and and to
have a catchy one at that you know i'm
saying like
i think it's very important though
in the in the beginning for sure these
[ __ ] gummies are strong as [ __ ]
how many did you did you just eat one
two oh you had two smack another one
oh you had three of them yeah that's not
a micro dose anymore look at the back of
that back bud
hey these [ __ ] wow sweet as a [ __ ]
you're currently uh in the touch of
reality phase if you look at the back of
the tops back
this is touch of reality
which one are we in the pre oh you guys
are in the morning microdose phase
you guys had one definitely somewhere
perfect i'm not here
hey look
oh my god
hey no look when he was sending tags i
wanted to say something about producers
with the tags right yeah a lot of [ __ ]
don't even worry about the beat and just
a tag be more important than the beat
like yeah girls [ __ ] behind me that's
the brandon he's crappy ass beats that
is true but i think like
with that i don't really want to speak
for them but like just with like a lot
of good producers like i think that's
the last thing i watch [ __ ]
just put so much emphasis on the tag
instead of making sure that a [ __ ]
could rap on this beat and make a dope
song
like a lot of producers this me speaking
from an artist standpoint
a lot of producers or beat makers they
make beats that's just a groove
you know what i'm saying it's a banging
ass beat but it's like damn [ __ ] where
i'll rap at you know what i'm saying all
right so it's like this is just like a
special art to having some [ __ ] that
that knock
and somewhere where you could rap at
that's why i think a lot of like these
simple beats that [ __ ] [ __ ] on they go
because
it's somewhere for the artist to rap on
and simply be getting busy and they go
you know what i mean
a lot of people do great music but it's
like
the cohesiveness of the vocals and then
hey what up we got to stop the podcast
real quick shout out to my bookie man
listen if you know anything about me you
know i like to gamble on sports and i've
been using my bookie for so long go to
mybookie.ag check it out they're doing
the my bookie double deposit bonus this
is how this works
you sign up you make a deposit you use
the promo code bootleg
and you're gonna get double your money
they're gonna match your deposit up to a
thousand dollars there's so much action
right now too the nba season is going
crazy maybe you could do a future right
who do you think is gonna win the mvp i
don't know is it gonna be honest is it
gonna be devin booker is it gonna be
jokic
certainly ain't gonna be [ __ ]
russell westbrook
crazy odds that ain't gonna happen
that's just burning money with that
being said there's so many different
ways you can bet you can bet on your
daily games you can do the parlay i like
doing moneyline parlays i like to just
do three or four heavy favorites on that
nba schedule throw them all on one
ticket and and just try to hit you know
what i'm saying whatever you're into my
bookie you could bet on it anything go
to mybookie.ag they got the double
deposit bonus right now this is
important sign up for an account make a
deposit and they will match your deposit
double your money up to a thousand
dollars right now that's free money so
what are you doing use the promo code
bootleg when you sign up and you can
double your money get in on some of this
nba action man it's nba season all-star
games this weekend so much to i mean you
could bet on the three-point contest the
[ __ ] dunk contest whatever the
[ __ ] is going on who's gonna be the mvp
of the all-star game i don't know but
you could bet on it you could bet on
anything so make sure one more time
that's my bookie double your first
deposit up to a thousand dollars using
that promo code bootleg place your bets
what are we doing bet on anything
anytime anywhere with my boogie
[ __ ] let's go don't mess well
you know i mean that is real there's so
many tags with uh
808 mafia or beats that i just always i
don't know how many people are in the
808 mafia but i feel like every random
ass rapper who's a nobody that i know
has a 808 mafia [ __ ] just like
they're like yeah i got i got stuff with
808 mafia i'm like yeah you and [ __ ]
98 other are we sure these are real 808
mafia beats or someone just take the tag
and put them on their shitty beats
and upsell you is that a thing yeah you
think yeah no that definitely isn't
there definitely
like almost like bootleg beats low key
like yeah definitely because i don't
hurt some beats with my attack on it
like what the [ __ ] really name and do
nothing
swear
or whatever you know they getting paid
do you guys do the online lease game
because there's good money yeah so
so i i'm i'm gonna get on to it
i'm just not used to it you know what
i'm saying like and i it was me kind of
being hollywood for a second but i had
to really think about it like how much
money are you leaving on the table on
the table you know what i'm saying like
being hollywood like oh i get this much
a beat
but then there's somebody that got you
know
their beats up and you know 150 people
bought this beat you know what i'm
saying i add up yeah like it adds up so
yeah
no it definitely has a i got homie who's
making like
five figures a month
who you wouldn't even know
just off of [ __ ] because he's his
youtube channel's doing his thing and
then people like the type beat game you
know like
putting up the
roddy rich type beat on youtube and then
the the link to lease it or whatever you
know what i'm saying like yeah loaded
great show me uh he he was showing me
you know like what what he was doing it
and you know it made complete sense but
yeah like i just think like as a
producer like you said like um
you know i manage a couple of producers
and i know that like the
it's just important to monetize
everything because if you're always
chasing placements you're going to be
[ __ ] stressed out it's going to suck
you're going to be in a [ __ ] studio
session someone might cut to your b and
then you're [ __ ] sitting on your
hands waiting to see if you could if you
could have if is it ever going to come
out or not oh you know i bet you that's
probably happened to your first bunch
chasing placements had me like not
making beats
for like
six months detective i remember rap [ __ ]
the pre used to call me like man what's
up what you doing like where you been at
like type [ __ ] but you know until really
g is like really what got me back on it
because like i was i was in studio
sessions
like just uncomfortable just like
hanging out in studio sessions waiting
for your chance to play beads
and
yeah and yeah especially if there's
other producers there it's like you
would rather
yo let's get in the studio and start on
something yeah you know everything is
hollywood now too so you know like there
i see it bro i don't see it i would
recommend producers to just find every
other way
of you know like
making money or you know like you don't
have to just go for like
the drakes and like all of them like
it's cool do that too but because it's
like other ways if you focus on only
that you're going to be hanging out in
studio sessions all [ __ ] night
with [ __ ]
with postmated bossa nova waiting for
your chance to play your beats and then
maybe uh someone cuts to your beat and
then you're gonna be like all right cool
when is it gonna drop is it ever going
to come out here from now on maybe maybe
not amazing
like yeah it's it's um
it's it's a man i i commend y'all
because the producer game is a tough one
man
it is but you just got to make it fun
y'all really gotta love it yeah that's
like people who do photography and do
graphic designs and do all this [ __ ] i'm
like man y'all really gotta love this
[ __ ] cause i don't feel like
you about to stand on the damn
chair for
[Applause]
that is a albino penis envy that is the
strain albino penis envy yeah yeah it's
a it's a problem like that it's a
popular strain of psilocybin mushrooms
which camera
is a [ __ ] this [ __ ] i'm not
gonna try
just to see yeah
you wanna try another piece
i'm good on the level i'm on bro let's
go half over all right he got to stand
up
[ __ ] tripping you know i'm finna trip
yeah like i'm a tree this [ __ ] i got a
blood outside so better you know what
clip of our interview with the most
crazy was the clip of you saying how you
eating an edible saved your life bro i
think i might be into some
today it might be some [ __ ] on the
horizon that i need to avoid because i'm
going to lay down after this
[Music]
this [ __ ]
i'm going to lay down after this for
sure oh my god just look keep you
tripping bro
first time this about to be a cold car
ride back
pray for me y'all
i got a blunt thought should be all
right how's the clothes doing
awesome bro like super awesome just
showing me some cool designs a little
shroom design [ __ ] bro i'm mad that i
didn't bring you something and you
definitely getting the
whole run of them shirts i'm gonna make
sure you on deck after this got you you
rightfully deserve to be the face of
that t-shirt but um
yeah the clothes doing great bro it's
um [ __ ] just been opening me up man like
it's crazy how music brings so much [ __ ]
to you you know what i'm saying facts
like i'm doing a uh i'm doing a drop
with a
with network for uh
network's dope yeah so i bought some
stuff off of there and then resold it
right and they called me to uh to work
with them but not as an artist as a
clothing
designer you know what i'm saying you'd
almost rather that so that was like
super dope you know what i mean like
okay my brand got me
like getting other looks that music
normally just just only music wouldn't
normally get me so i mean it's doing
great bro it's people calling we
stealing um
and [ __ ] um
[Laughter]
i'm [ __ ] high as a [ __ ] but
we still in um
[ __ ]
uh damn i can't say it
really think
where are you still in
the clothing line is still in the
is it a store yes which store look let's
see
oh [ __ ] bro
anyway the clothing line is in a gang of
different department stores it's in a
gang of different retails we're not a
gang of different retailers one specific
retail we're mainly online
um
and it's doing great man you know what
i'm saying and it uh
it's just showing me how to operate
you know as a businessman that i need to
just have structure
around that in order for it to keep
going because like as an artist you
could get lucky dropping something
one time oh this is a dope ass idea
everybody buy it right [ __ ] with it but
the catch is being able to get them to
[ __ ] with it you know continuously make
it a piece of that lifestyle you know
what i'm saying
make it you know what i'm saying you
know beyond lifestyle they like what
life is lifestyle so you know just make
it um day-to-day form you know i'm
saying meaning that every time you drop
something whether it be a hat
ashtray
whatever it is they're gonna pick it up
they with the movement of the brain you
know what i'm saying and it's do you
like going like [ __ ]
when you like because obviously we're in
l.a there's the garment district you go
pick like the pieces you want to print
your [ __ ] on yourself or do you have
other people handle all that [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah i'm i'm real hands-on
the quality of everything is high so
it's like i even like i just packed like
500 orders
wow like myself the other night yeah i
mean yeah i'd be on facetime just like
[ __ ] it i'm about to just do this [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying you saw
something like i'm real
like some of the [ __ ] though like some
of the [ __ ] i signed and i still did
some extra [ __ ] for people but uh like
if they spent like you're like yo these
these fools drop the bag let me uh throw
something in here right right right so
you'll catch a rare moment where i pack
orders but for most of the time i just
pay somebody to do that but um like i
like to be hands-on with as much as
possible so i know just you know
everything they got to do with the
business just in case somebody like man
we can't do this we can't wait hold up i
know how to it's not that hard you know
what i'm saying kick back i can handle
it you know what i mean have you linked
up with uh david sebastian yet david
sebastian yeah yeah yeah david sebastian
dope man i remember when i got up on him
was uh
at a juneteenth
he performed like in front of my shop on
renondo [ __ ] and um
i'm like this dude dope like he
commanded the whole
he commanded the whole block when he got
the air and made it a vibe you know what
i'm saying so i've been on him since
then
but we yet uh his clothing line is um
you know he's doing like the like i
don't know if you saw the kanye's like
having homeless people model his clothes
yeah that's all through
a collab with david sebastian's clothing
line skid row
wow so yeah i should do it y'all should
do the uh little you know a little blue
tea
skid row collab man it's a no-brainer we
gotta do it yeah and you guys can eat
rooms together because he is a shroom
guy
actual natural shroom not the gummies
huh no the gummies are it bro
the natural
you got to stuff them in like a peanut
butter sandwich or something
if i ever get to that point yeah
that's why you may that's why you eat
these because these at least you you
know there's some sort of like guide
when you eat the natural [ __ ]
you might get a cat that's [ __ ] ill
i had that a couple months you had
experience with with the wrong one no
not a capsule it was you had a battery
microdose yeah what was it i got it from
one of his friends
hey bro
what does a bad trip consists of what
was your bad trip like i was just
tripping like i i just was feeling like
real weird like my head was spinning
like i was sweating a lot and that's
what made me stop taking shrooms around
that time yeah like when i laid down it
felt like i was falling so i kept
getting up oh [ __ ] like yeah and it was
it lasted for like two hours did you ha
did you hallucinate about like did you
see anything no no i didn't hallucinate
i did that off of edible before i feel
like i've i've hallucinated off of an
edible yeah bro animals are i'm not the
one they're the devil that's why i was
scared it is because i tripped out on
the edible bro so i'm like yeah i mean
you had two pieces strong you had two
pieces yeah you had two pieces but but
if you ate that whole bag you might i
ate three of the pieces
but if you ate the whole bag you might
have like you know a conversation with
jesus or something oh we i would never
eat the whole bag bro just imagine
having a conversation with jesus like
you could never come back like same
person
you gonna change now i know your videos
i do want to talk to him but just not at
this moment i just got a couple more
your whole life outlook how you approach
it yeah why wouldn't you eat the whole
bag
i mean you don't want to talk to jesus
right yeah bro that's why we gotta talk
to you
what would you ask if you if g what
would you ask jesus though why they
hating on me
jesus
i don't know i'll probably be like why
am i up here talking to you right now
i'd be like man this whole time i
thought no i thought she wasn't real bro
been telling everybody i'm an atheist
i've been full of [ __ ]
i'll be like jesus look man let's make a
deal
you know what i mean what kind of deal
would you make with it yeah let me give
you a let me give you a blue t-shirt hey
take a selfie in this blue shirt
yeah i already gave my you know confess
before the lord and everything he didn't
already get his love amen i'm saved
could you sell your soldier to the lord
i've never heard
let's make a deal right why don't we
just all become scientists go to the
lord and say let's make a deal yeah
really yeah yo them scientologists fools
and they always have money that's a real
ass cult that's that's some wild [ __ ] i
mean most religion is kind of cultish
right but like yeah for sure scientology
is [ __ ] yeah it's just my life
when you think about it you gotta
believe in some [ __ ] you've never seen
before i've never really touched you and
believe that
is helping you and changing your life
you know what i'm saying which you know
everybody got to believe in something
right this this is true i believe i just
believe in my enterprise clique
you know what i mean i don't believe in
that you know i believe in enterprise
click over jesus because i you're here
in front of me
enterprise clinton you heard him well i
am extremely i'm very anti-religious so
you know i think a lot of this [ __ ] is
all man-made and you know my thing is
just belonging to a uh specific religion
it's like joining the gang mm-hmm you're
like agnostic you believe in a higher
power you believe in god but there's
just that's me for sure
i believe i believe
i belong to
but allegedly
well not so legendary yeah there's a
motion
because i'm a businessman i'm much more
than that but you know for a long part
of my life i belong to that but you know
right now i belong to this enterprise
click [ __ ] that giant bbg tattoo how
painful was that it didn't hurt it
didn't hurt no you know that [ __ ] hurt
bro you were calling me like bro
so was it worse than the removal
or what not the removal don't really
look like a hurt
like they only go over at one time i'm
getting he coming to the house after
this you're getting some [ __ ] removed
yeah what are you getting removed on my
neck i ain't gonna lie i'm cleaning up
my whole little i don't know what side
it's on but
i gotta tap right here i ain't gonna lie
you you look like you was trying to look
comfortable but you look like you was in
bed no they just go off that [ __ ]
it's just once
yeah they go over it pop bop or a tice
one time and then back it's like 10
minutes
and it's gone and then where is it
oh cause it's a bunch of different
treatments right it's about it's gonna
take about like 12 sessions they said
for it to go away i mean it smell bad
dark as a [ __ ] like this smell
the smell and then it's like part of it
on my throat
so i could taste it coming through my
throat you could taste the ink when it's
come like damn it's this [ __ ]
even like safe
because i need my you know what i'm
saying yeah
yeah i'm around you're gonna end up like
[ __ ]
goddammit what kind of dlc no yeah the
dlc yeah oh yeah i need my vocals you
know i'm saying i thought about that
[ __ ] too like damn if i ever lose my
voice
like this you'll be on movie rosie's
[ __ ] only fans me being able to talk
you know what i'm saying like
from the beginning of time whatever it
was i was selling don't
pimp it you know what i'm saying
i never was a jacker you know what i
mean music um these companies walking in
these offices
it's like i need my i need my vocals man
[ __ ] can't talk you know i'm
saying i've been talking my way into
some bags like
over m's to the [ __ ] in blue
you know throughout life
that's a lot of money yeah
you're [ __ ] i spend money like it's
like i thought about it the other day i
said damn
i i can't even tell you like if i was to
put my finger on something like how does
this [ __ ] how do i make money
man i can't just do it your voice that's
how i am people be like i can't tell you
i just got [ __ ] i think about like
well not 10 years ago i was balling in
too but
like it been time
it been times in between the last time i
saw you you were showing me your new
[ __ ] was it an impala you were monte
carlo
you have a serious car issue yeah yeah
yeah yeah i'm on the opposite side
somebody stole the keys today my vehicle
[ __ ] car my car's paid off it's also
2007 sequoia but it's paid off you know
hey man that's the right
but it's like i just be thinking about
evolution like i was driving up i stayed
on magnolia on the other end of magnolia
when i first got out of jail and [ __ ] in
the valley yeah and the rent was like
1200 a month 1300 a month and it's like
man i couldn't i never lived in no spot
like this and then the homies remember
when i said that last night
and he like oh you bougie and it's like
when i think about it it's like damn
like [ __ ] think his way into the spicy
yeah for real what made you get out of
the valley
my daughter my daughter mom moved to l.a
so
just to be able to uh
stay for she could be close to her mom
and go to a night school i just moved in
i feel like you know so many artists
like will leave la to go to the valley
just to just get away from the hood a
lot of valleys
but do you feel like so many
people have moved to the valley now that
it's like still some like you might go
to the [ __ ] corner store and run into
running for sure because the valley's
kind of active now we were saying that
too look we ride up some over there and
see see a [ __ ] i'm like
the the just the street in me was ready
to bust to you and you just sweating
[ __ ] like what's up
but it's like me in the valley bro you
know what i'm saying like i'm like i'm
driving this is this is over a year ago
so it doesn't matter uh but i'm like
[ __ ] driving down lankershim over
here on magnolia
and just mozzies crossing the street you
know like to go by himself to go to hot
dave's hot chicken
over 12 months ago
but i was like yo
and i was like
you know
everybody who's around everybody
involved and they all live like right
here or they're all recorded like right
here like the valley is like
i ain't gonna lie i miss being in the
valley within the same couple of blocks
everybody you gonna run into everybody
everybody got a [ __ ] studio over here
it's not [ __ ] crazy and it only makes
sense like
all right you got the the rapper
district you got the fashion district
you got this you got that you know what
you're seeing
like there was a very popular rapper who
was on my show yesterday who
probably uh
you know there's some
perceived smoke going on with this guy
and we're just standing on the corner
and i'm just like
yo man like yeah but like we're on the
corner of magnolia and kawanga just
hanging out like the hood though it's
not so it's good but it's because it's
like this look
when you outside of the ghetto
because this is the thing about la right
every area
is
it's like it's an army around that
[ __ ]
so if you caught on any of these blocks
[ __ ] could get online you know this
nigga's coming out of spots
like [ __ ] like this if i
crack i still got to get to safety
after
everything transpired you know what i'm
saying or
you know however it might end
[ __ ] still got to get somewhere
low so
you know out here eric it's all even
playing field how um but we ain't
looking for that we getting money no i
was gonna say how how like when it comes
to like some of your younger homies or
from where you're from
how um
like do you try to give them advice do
you try to make sure that they're
yeah like anybody that'll listen but
like when i was growing up i wasn't
like
i was a little different though it's
like sometimes i ain't gonna hear that
[ __ ] but i'll be really hearing that
[ __ ] you know i'm saying i'd be acting
like [ __ ] i ain't trying to hear that
but me like
so
you know i just be whoever want to
listen and whoever i see potential in
you know what i'm saying and when
whenever one of the young homies is
ready to listen i know they gonna come
to me
because it it in the ghetto bro it's so
much like dumbass pride
like
[ __ ] be so prideful for no [ __ ]
apparent reason besides [ __ ]
[ __ ] don't need no [ __ ] and
the [ __ ]
that [ __ ] get fed you know what i'm
saying i don't need nobody i'm tougher
than everybody this that and the other i
ain't gonna be listening no [ __ ] no
[ __ ] finna have no over but not
realizing that um
in this world like it's full of people
for a reason people make this [ __ ] go
around so you need people you need
relationships you need somebody that you
could get gained from and guide you in
the right direction you know what i'm
saying ain't nothing wrong with that so
yeah like whoever whoever want to listen
like i'm open to like [ __ ] with
giving [ __ ] all the game that i got
for sure hey we gotta stop the podcast
man real quick appreciate y'all for
watching uh really mean mean it
subscribe like leave a comment even if
you're one of those [ __ ] who leaves
a comment yo why you always interrupting
the guests because it's my [ __ ]
podcast i don't know i like to talk too
anyway
hey shout out to odd socks man they've
been our sponsor from day one we go hard
for odd socks always man
literally go hard for my wife and i go
hard for odd socks
in different and same kinds of ways you
know what i'm saying sometimes i go hard
in odd socks
they do make boxers
you feel me
anyway um listen they got the ill
licenses they got the breaking bad they
got the wwe they got mountain dew they
got [ __ ] swedish fish [ __ ]
kool-aid
uh
pez you know
cheech and chong what are you into the
odd socks basics are the boys though
that's my favorite you know you get
yourself a nice pair of just basics
they're comfy it's like walking on
clouds all right so you can save 20 off
if you go to oddssoxofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg kev that's
one word bootleg kev
all together
at checkout 20 off oddssoxofficial.com
go show some love and let's get back to
the interview
what would be some uh producer advice
you guys would give to upcoming
producers i know a lot of producers
these days are getting on with like just
sending out loops you know certain [ __ ]
like that like what would be some advice
you guys would give so like my biggest
advice that i give to new producers
is like first of all conquer your city
if you can get your city behind you
you know you can expand and that's kind
of like
how i did it um and i will uh also say
just be original like
there's always
like rules to producing like you need
you know your kicks go here your claps
go here but you know like when you're
doing melodies and like stuff like that
you always think out the box because if
you can make that dope like you got a
better chance of starting what's new
rather than following what you know
everybody else is doing because only a
couple of people are gonna get on
doing that certain thing
and you know it's always somebody that
comes and changes the landscape and
that's you know those are the ones that
usually you know we remember right
that's real what about you
oh what i would say to up like to
up-and-coming producer i would say like
like stay consistent
and lock in with an artist that like
fits your sound because i think that's
important trying to chase like you know
superstars if you blocking with one guy
maybe with that one they're dope they're
on the come up or they're just someone
you believe in and you do a whole
project with them or you lock and
develop a sound with them that [ __ ] to
me is super important that's like most
important like that's like the gym and i
like summers i would say like deal i
would say like build that you know i
mean like like like build relationships
like don't worry about like that quick
check yeah you built the relationships
you built the catalog i didn't build
relationships with like g tiger like so
i'm always going to be on like their
projects yeah and like nowadays if
you're independent and let's say you're
a producer and you're [ __ ] with an
artist and you all do an album drop it
on disc joe kid and just set up the
splits and you get what i'm saying
you're getting paid off of the [ __ ]
streams you know what i'm saying like
you might not sell 10 beats to that
artist but you guys can be partners on
the on the project you know yeah and
that's advice from producers who who've
been doing this [ __ ] for 10 years
and you know like are just learning the
importance of locking in with the artist
versus
trying to send out beats and you know oh
and then just speaking on like sending
the beats i was just add on to just
saying like
don't get discouraged like if you send a
beat like today and like the artists
don't say it or even if they read it you
know i mean like wait the next day or
next day like use that as motivation
because i didn't have certain artists
even with this guy i sent him a beat on
tuesday he won't get back to me like
till next saturday right now i'm saying
but i'm still sending him [ __ ] within
that process when someone's like yo send
me a pack
what would you guys suggest like because
sometimes it's like it's over
it's overkill right somebody will send
you a [ __ ] man
i'm saying i'm gonna text you to beats
man cuz that pack [ __ ] can get caught up
in the loop with the evening i mean yeah
thousand other producers i mean like
nowadays for me i like to go in and
create more than what the heart packs
like i sent a couple but like
it's better for me to to actually get in
and make something new from scratch with
the artist so that way yeah that's real
or just vibe if i'm not making something
from scratch it'll be good to get in
with the artist so we could just buy
about because i didn't got placements
just selling the beat the baby could be
regular but me just i'm a cool dude i'm
a vibe with you i'm saying they get that
vibe and it's like we got a record so
that's dope yeah i ain't gonna lie i
don't even listen to beat packs like
[ __ ] i'm saying [ __ ] and i look at all
that
you know like
it's been so many times where a
[ __ ] played some [ __ ] for me
like even these [ __ ] like and it's
like i've been sent you this [ __ ] it's
like i never checked that email yeah
for you as an artist [ __ ] beat packs
because when i did it'd be like
all right this part of the beat is tight
especially if it's not my producers
this part of the beat is tight but like
i said earlier where do i fit in at on
this [ __ ] because they forget
that and we can't re-go in on it and
redo it like i'm not even [ __ ] it i
don't care yeah the cool thing about g
is when he he got a vision so he'll hear
something and i might have produced it
and he might hear something that he
wants the pre to do on it so he might be
like take this out or you know send this
here you know like we just yeah you got
that luxury right because if it's just
some random producer from atlanta and
they send you a beat you like i might
like this but where you at to send like
let's stand this [ __ ] out let's yeah
bro and it's rare that i find a beat
where i just like rap over the whole
[ __ ] and i don't need nothing change
it's like all right it's too heavy right
here my voice is clashing with this [ __ ]
i don't um you know what i'm saying like
i used to do that [ __ ] but now it's like
right now no we just making music and
having fun so that pack [ __ ]
listen you've been dropping a bunch of
[ __ ] but what's what's like what's
what's this all leading up to
south central the album like the album
album south central and then hot shot
the album so two albums this year like
you know and then just a gang of
projects tango steel g slim
me and j nori wing put a name on our
project me and lo the great
it's a lot of projects coming on the way
a lot of leaks
l.a summers too oh yeah i forgot about
that and it's just a lot of projects and
a lot of leaks that we got coming
because it's just
like i said bro we [ __ ]
we paving the way for this new era bro
it's a streaming era it's a new
underground era and the market and the
scene is untapped in la everybody want
to do [ __ ] and get signed
and fake look good and fake be rich you
know what i'm saying like we really
getting
to it and you know
like this summer we gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] up
cause i you know
be out here
how that money carlo put together
care about me pounding them south
central blocks
yeah this guy did get a new monte carlo
yeah
that bubble back window yeah the bubble
back window look fly yeah and you got a
deal on it you're telling me you came up
yeah yeah yeah when i told oh boy i'm
like yeah bro um
[Music]
like the bank that i'm with they don't
really give i got to order the cash so
it's like bro i ain't gonna be up with
it
um
can i give you a cashier's check
and he like uh
man you i gotta go to the bank with you
for that i'm like listen bro
my name's you parika wait wait wait jeep
rico everything changed what pen you was
in and uh whoopty woo whoa
i'm like delano you like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] it was one of my partners i was in
the pen waiting [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
it worked out
so when you get a new car do you sell a
car or just keep them all
yeah i don't i never sold a car in my
life
you know if you were to sell a car never
sold now is the time to sell either give
[ __ ] away
you're giving cars away [ __ ] get [ __ ]
totaled out uh
it go to the impound if i ain't got no
license on and go get it like it's all
right yeah i just wish
you had a car get you've had a car you
impounded and you just left it yeah hell
yeah plenty of times how many
a lot when i have no license that's
terrible right i've never sold one a car
ever well you know i just give it to
somebody there's a chance there's a chip
shortage right now so if you wanted to
sell now'd be the time because cars are
[ __ ] exciting i know my truck like 30
000 more than what i got it for right
now sell it
but it's like i don't even care to sell
it like might as well get that extra
third
let me get another car
see with me and cars it's a different
combo it's like i just like having the
[ __ ] so it's like it's like a
real bond i just it seems like like
some wraps and some t-shirts and you
can't let go of the way that extra 30.
other [ __ ] but it's like
i just like cars bro are you um because
you're obviously i'm gonna get a
warehouse soon and just go up the same
way
it's going to be like jayla i know our
[ __ ] garage
jalen will be riding around burbank all
the time in the most wild-ass cars on
the hollywood way
he should
that's really where my uh my passion at
in my life like you just gonna see me in
vehicles like moving i figured it out
that's what i'm doing
outside of this music [ __ ] but you know
i'm spending all my money on that
getting my shoulder to rest i feel like
um like when you're on rock nation
you know this guy's got [ __ ] his his
thing ringing over there
um no when when you were on
when you were on rock nation i feel like
you know i feel like you have your core
fan base and you you're really really
you're i don't want to
[Music]
uh historically a west coast uh sonic
sonically that's where your base is
right that's the music you make right
and i feel like sometimes when you have
a [ __ ] hardcore fan base the way you
do
it's it's easy to
start chasing
atlanta or toronto or new york or all
this [ __ ] and when you do that you start
[ __ ] souring the people who keep the
lights on
exactly i fell into that [ __ ] how you
want it how you feel i hate that [ __ ]
record um
[ __ ] um
big stacks big stack that's like chasing
the [ __ ] fam like check this out
trying to get a single right and it's
like the [ __ ] that we do and just throw
it out it's stream warning all that [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying with no money
put into it so
it's like yeah i gotta just stick to the
core because i was gonna say are you
worried about like does that even
concern you to ever even like because i
feel like
you just keep doing what you're doing
and like that [ __ ] will just come on its
own exactly like the world will come to
you as opposed to you trying to force
your way into like getting played a
magic city or some [ __ ] you know right
yeah i told myself this i said with the
with the amount of work that we putting
in and just all the different [ __ ] that
we bring into the culture
you know what i mean and we making it
noticeable instead of doing it you know
in a um
uh like in a passive way you know what
i'm saying right we like letting our
nuts hang right right right right
you gotta give yourself credit exactly
because it's like would you rather just
be like a [ __ ] that's overrated or
underrated but anyway uh
i've been telling myself like i know i'm
an influence the entire generation
whether it's now
or
it might happen after my time right you
know what i'm saying i might be long
gone and i just influenced the whole
entire all these [ __ ] sampling me and
what was g thinking and you know what
i'm saying so
that's what i'd be thinking about like i
know that
like it's gonna be a gang of
[ __ ] inspired by what i do how
i think and the [ __ ] that i'm saying you
know what i'm saying so
that's my whole
like that's my driving force behind it
like it's bigger than just a quick song
cause like i know how to get on how to
get money like you know what i'm saying
yeah as we've established
it's like i gotta be thinking like what
do i be doing i'll just be getting money
i don't even rise
for some reason i always got money with
my boy uh mike f say some [ __ ] like that
shout out to mike epps yeah
indianapolis's finest right there well
[ __ ] so uh what's what's next
we're gonna take some more of these
[ __ ] right here okay i'm saying
we finna get high as [ __ ] the rest of
the day
yeah i mean then [ __ ] the day off
and get back to it tomorrow there it is
man um uh what's up what's up you guys
got some uh yeah what's any placements
coming down the pipeline or um yeah i
got a couple of stuff like i'm i'm
really trying to get my stuff off the
ground like uh i'm working on getting a
little situation with a empire
and then like just putting out stuff
with my you know like artists i work
with you know yeah i feel like you um
you guys shrooms making the light
brighter or something i feel like
there's no like like like um you know
the approach i've been taking with my
producer i work with tony chalk is like
i'm like bro
you know we did a whole album with the
artist named caskey who used to be
signing cash money white boy tatted a
fire as [ __ ] but he's got a crazy
following right
so we did the whole album and i was like
look we'll just do it just he's got to
be primary artists on there with you
so like on spotify if you go to my
producer's
profile it's lit as [ __ ] like he got
like 150 000 monthly listeners
and so now we can start charging for
leases
and yeah and so we did a whole album
with demeric who's from la you know and
he's primary artist on the album it's
like you know but you got to do y'all
got to do the same [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying yeah like start building up
that artist that that's those spotify
profiles because if people go and see
janari's profile and you got 250 000
monthly listeners they're like oh [ __ ]
what's going on here
i know and they'd be looking at yeah
like gian got [ __ ] cracking look up we
million monthly right 800 monthly
listeners and then that gives you the
opportunity if you're leasing beats
you're doing whatever you'd be like yo
man like i got i got catalog too like
outside of my placements i got catalog
as like a
a real collaborative artist on this [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying right so get on
him so when y'all drop these records
y'all are primary artists on the joints
you know what i'm saying that's all on
him it's him
[Music]
it's the click baby
all right
that being said i gotta take a piss
take one of these rooms dawg we should
have that's why i gotta drop this whole
interview we gotta damn near restart
this [ __ ] i gotta drive i gotta take
some shrooms bro i gotta drive to
phoenix right now i'll take one you
gotta drive to phoenix yeah [ __ ] my
niece's quinceanera is going down that
ain't even friday oh kingston yeah sweet
16.
i don't know about those huh
you know i love hispanic girls hey man
shout out to my mom hold on where do you
think rico came from like shout out to
my wife my hispanic
well not even that wasn't my girlfriend
just somebody i was born in back in the
day damn she called you parika
she tell she told me how to spell it i
used to spell it wrong damn yeah i mean
she like oh i had it on headbands and
wristbands this when i was like a
teenager and [ __ ]
she's like are you spelling it wrong how
you spelling i'm like oh okay i spelt it
with a d
i c o p i d wait what wait
i forgot it was a like
i was naked
and she's like nah you spell it like
this
yeah
but i have nothing to say about your
statement you just made because i don't
know what that means
[Music]
podcast
go follow these guys go buy a blue
t-shirt
[ __ ] don't stop baby
still collect